but everywhere the real issue is Islam
in Europe and the end of course the
interesting question is that secular
Europe suddenly finds themselves
Christian not because they are believers
again but because there are cultural
identity as long as they define as Islam
as non-european it means that then they
cannot be like us because they are not
Christian or they are not secular which
is interesting because there was a time
when the turkey can join us because its
secular turkey well cannot join us yet
because they have not yet the rides a
constitution the democratic practices
they are not developed but they are
already secular so they could join us
now the paradox is the more democratic
turkey becomes and the more it meets all
the conditions to join the European
Union which is a constitution they say
shoulder loss the more Islamic Muslim
their politics become so the more
democratic turkey turkey becomes the
more mass and now European oh no they
cannot join us but we we met all day you
told us you have to become like that
like that but we but you didn't have to
become Muslim why not you had Christian
Democratic parties were not the
Christian Democratic Party's the one
that established the European Union the
Treaty of Rome was established by
Christian Democratic parties and
basically on Benedicta x by x by the
Pope I mean it was all all the ruling
party's in in five countries were
christian democratic and only in France
they were not rulers but they were the
leader French politicians of the
European Union were all Christian
Democrats the main figures but we have
forgotten is a story and of course we
are saying well you have to be either
Christian or secular you cannot be Islam
you cannot be Muslim mass and the mock
democracy is not possible I mean Kristen
democracy was possible so again it's a
very our confused categories within
Europe and these are very interesting
debate do they have to become like us
and how like us meaning they have to
become Christian or second